the topic of Taxation comes up on the
program a lot and the reason it comes up
is because taxes are both a political
issue and an economic issue and a social
issue when it comes to what our
society's priorities via taxation and
who we want to be taxing so just as like
some examples for you we've talked about
what is the tax rate that maximizes
revenue for the government and who
should be taxed at what rate in order to
obtain the maximum amount of revenue
before tax has become a disincentive to
productivity how do certain tax plans
impact people on the basis of the amount
of money that they make have tax cuts
and tax increases historically help the
economy or hurt the economy and how do
we measure it is it better for the
economy to cut or raise taxes on the
rich what about on the poor what about
the middle class supply side versus
demand side we've talked about all of
those things before and I'm not going to
talk about any of those things today
okay what I'm going to focus in on today
is the legal basis for taxation in the
United States not generally the legal
basis for taxation around the world or
as a concept but in the United States
what is the legal basis for taxation now
you might wonder if you're a reasonable
person why the hell are you going to
talk about that obviously it's legal for
the government to tax people well it
might be obvious to you but there are
people to whom it is not obvious this
relates to the group that says taxation
is theft or the government is stealing
or even that taxation is actually
illegal and it's good to know exactly
how to respond because the real
conversations we should be having are
the ones we've been having on the show
that I mentioned two minutes ago but to
get to that point you need to get past
the objections that some people have
which are that taxes are just
straight-up illegal so first of all I
can't refute every version of the
there's no law that says you have to pay
taxes argument because there are dozens
and dozens of versions of that argument
but I'm going to lay out a general free
work for you that will at least give you
a starting point to talk to people when
they make these assertions so we'll
start with the legal portion then we'll
talk about the ideological portion which
is more the idea of taxes being theft
the general right to collect taxes is in
the Constitution specifically it's in
the sixteenth Amendment of the Bill of
Rights and it says quote the Congress
shall have power to lay and collect
taxes on incomes from whatever source
derived without apportionment among the
several states and without regard to any
census or enumeration the key word there
is incomes what counts as taxable
incomes well for information on that we
go to the united states code of law 26
subsection 63 which says that taxable
income is simply gross income - allowed
deductions tax law enumerates what
deductions are available to people this
includes stuff like the mortgage
interest deduction or loss carryovers
all of these different things that we
talk about on a year-to-year basis and
that's how your income is defined so
that gets us to you must pay taxes all
right that is in the Constitution and
that's in the United States code of law
but some people will argue where does
the law say that you have to file a tax
return every year what about that
element well we also go to the United
States code of law for that United
States code 26 subsection 6 0 1 2 which
requires the filing of tax returns by
every individual who has gross income
for the year and there are dozens and
dozens of legal cases that have upheld
this so now I know that this is so
general that there will be anti-tax
people who will write to me and they'll
say David you know what you're ignoring
when you tell us about this are the
technicalities or the semantics or
particular wordings that they assert
prove taxation is illegal but the bottom
line is as a general framework when
people say there's no
law that says the government can collect
taxes the sixteenth Amendment plus the
United States code of law plus dozens of
cases worth of legal precedent laid out
very very clearly constitutional law
scholars pay their taxes because they
know that it's legal
accountants pay their taxes because they
know that they have to economists pay
their taxes taxation is legal so let's
now move on to the sort of more
ideological political argument that
taxes are theft okay the main argument
is that taxation is theft because you
don't have a choice about paying taxes
if you don't pay your taxes men with
guns as they like to say will show up
and put you in jail or prison it's an
initiation of force and therefore
taxation is theft in the ideological
political sense but number one men with
guns is an argument for improper
initiations of force is silly in and of
itself I don't want to focus on that
piece today because I feel like it's not
really central to what we're really
trying to figure out here there is a
social contract which includes taxation
enforcing taxation by the government is
merely enforcing that contract now
anti-tax libertarians will say I never
signed that contract how can I be party
to a contract that I never signed or
agreed to participate in well actually
you did okay one possibility is that
your parents chose for you to live in
the United States after you were born
they have power of custody that's the
law and you therefore are part of the
social contract that is the United
States of America because of the
decision your parents made when they had
custody of you and you can leave at any
time if you can find another country
that will have you that relates to the
law of other countries not to the United
States
if you immigrated to the United States
you signed the contract called the USA
when you took your oath of citizenship
you swore to uphold our laws which
include taxation as described into the
Constitution sixteenth Amendment and the
United States called
code of law if you're not a citizen but
you're here as a permanent resident or
on a visa or with a green card you did
the exact same thing as part of
receiving that apparatus which allows
you to be in the United States legally
the fact that you may not have
physically signed it is really
meaningless if you go to a restaurant
and order food would it be valid to say
I don't really owe the restaurant any
money because I didn't sign a contract
no that would be a really dumb argument
it would be a childish libertarian
argument and that's exactly the argument
that they are making when they say that
taxation is theft now let's go to the
next part of their argument which is
that you don't have the option not to
pay taxes to the American government
that's also not true and it really comes
down to what do you mean by options if
you truly don't want to pay taxes to the
United States government for whatever
reason you have the option of not
working that's your call how you survive
would be up to you to figure out in the
libertarian paradise but it is your call
if you don't want to pay taxes one way
is not to have any income number two you
can leave the country now as I mentioned
you would then be subject to the laws of
other countries in terms of whether you
could even live and work in those
countries and by the way other countries
also have taxes so that would be sort of
a practical limitation you can also
lobby to have the law changed so that
there are no more taxes now I think it
would be difficult to do that because
most people understand that we need
taxes humans not in a state of nature
working in groups that are bigger than a
hundred and fifty people to pick a sort
of evolutionary relevant number need
taxes there's simply no other way to
carry out a lot of these basic
mechanisms for human life so I think it
would be difficult to go ahead and
convince enough of the population that
we don't need taxes but you could also
Lobby to have the law change you could
lobby your elected officials or whoever
else and then number four you could also
just take a chance on not paying your
taxes and see if you get caught maybe
you wouldn't that would certainly be a
choice the
you would have to make so taxes are not
illegal the sixteenth amendment the
united states code of law lay all of
that out and taxes are also not theft
you have a number of different options
if you don't want to pay taxes to the
United States of America
this is relevant shockingly because
there is a surprisingly high portion of
libertarians that believe this now I
know that lots of sane libertarians will
say I'm really more of a social
libertarian I I'm more of a
constitutional libertarian or they will
apply civil libertarian other words to
it but there are libertarians that
believe this stuff and you have to get
past this in order to get to what I
consider to be the really important
questions about taxation meaning what
should be the priorities of taxation who
should be paying taxes how much should
they be paying and how should that money
be spent and what the society most
benefit benefit from the usage of those
taxes on if I'm missing something if you
think that the legal framework that I've
laid out is not sufficient to defend
taxation as a legal mechanism I want to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at Dee
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show let me know and I will
be more than willing to have my mind
changed if you make a coherent and
compelling argument